si la cancillera a las ocho y media de
la noche hora local
el apagado simbólico de luces que
solamente una cuestión para que todos
tomemos conciencia el apagado simbólico
de los principales monumentos y
edificios del mundo entre los que está
el cristo del entorno en río de janeiro
la puerta de brandenburgo en berlín el
vaticano la basílica san pedro en el
vaticano y numerosos monumentos más se
lleva a cabo justamente como tú lo dices
a las ocho y media de ocho y media a
nueve y media de la noche hora local es
decir la hora del planeta' da la vuelta
al mundo empieza en australia en otras
latitudes de nueva zelanda y empieza a
dar la vuelta al mundo hasta llegar
justamente a américa y es muy importante
que en esa hora todos tomemos conciencia
de lo que podemos hacer por la
naturaleza podemos hacer desde asistir a
los eventos de apagado que va a haber en
algunos lugares a teniendo por supuesto
las restricciones sanitarias hasta
actividades que podemos hacer en casa
que tienen que ver por ejemplo con hacer
una dieta sustentable tomar conciencia a
revisar nuestro refrigerador ver que no
haya comida que se vaya echar y entender
que tenemos que comprar alimentos de una
manera distinta consumir menos plástico
tener una lectura en familia a la luz de
las velas contar un cuento podemos hacer
muchas actividades en nuestra casa sin
necesariamente este año salir de ella